it might not look like much but this $35
assembly of electronics is a fully
functioning computer there's the ARM
chip right here tons of USB ports and
Ethernet port even an HDMI port with
this teeny little thing you can do just
about anything
released in 2012 the PI has inspired
near religious devotion among cheeky
hobbyists and inventors some of them
show off their PI creations at things
called raspberry jams I went to see
David pride who has a shrine to the
low-cost personal computer at his home
in Gloucester what is this little device
meant to you it's changed my life I was
very happy very stable had a nice
well-paid job but I was very very bored
and I realized that whatever wanted to
do something different this was this was
the opportunity to learn the skills that
I'd always wanted to learn electronics
robotics coding his house is littered
with pie creations from motorised cars
to robots greetings to everyone watching
Phil oh well that's a nice touch his
most famous invention though is the four
BOTS an AI infused machine that plays a
mean albeit slow game of Connect four
that is cool
how long did it take you to make this
about three months of evenings and
weekends
connect four is actually quite a complex
game there's an awful lot of mathematics
behind the AI that runs the system so it
makes it you even though I have to go
you make your move but it is now
thinking about the move it's taken
oh you bastard you've just lost I feel
ashamed I feel like I should tell more
for the humans
to really understand the soul of the
Raspberry Pi
I had to head to its birthplace in
Cambridge and dig deep into the city's
traditions
this meant humiliating myself through
something called punting which is like
canoeing except dumber and more
frustrating whoa all right Oh June so
you pull it all the way else yeah yeah
how do people deal is that he's pretty
intuitive my punting coach is having
Upton easy
he's the cambridge computer scientist
who invented the pie around 2007 Evan
grew alarmed by the declining number of
computer science students in England and
decided to try and inspire the
youngsters with a new approach I've
always assumed Cambridge is the best
place in the world to study computer
science it's certainly the best place in
the UK and we saw this collapse and a
number of people applying to study
computer science at the University of
Cambridge which is crazy as their
computing industries blow yeah yeah yeah
communities playing obviously it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful environment
to come and to come and study in the
theory we came up with was that um most
of us who were arriving in the mid-90s
like I did I had grown up with cheap
programmable 8-bit microcomputers you
grew up using the BBC micro my grads
what got you again until I had a BBC
micro school and start the corner of the
classroom and those were beautiful
machines supported by the UK government
the BBC micro gave many students their
first taste of coding and the
possibility of what computers could do I
suave the pie has very much followed in
this tradition and emerged as a consumer
hit along the way it's now the third
best-selling computer of all time behind
the Mac in the PC our lifetime dream
volume was 10,000 units now we're
closing them on 10 million but as that's
happened we've just got more ambitious
we just got more greedy I guess about
what we're trying to accomplish we've
gone from can we move the needle from
200 to 600 people applying to computer
science at Cambridge - yeah can we do
the same for other universities can we
do the same for other countries could we
do the same for other subjects think big
Jason Statham impersonator think big
you